toujours le climat de violence en
nouvelle calédonie et un européen a été
tué la nuit dernière mais le broussard
que l'on avait cru mort hier a seulement
été blessé du serpent de mer au tunnel
l'angleterre peut être bientôt relié au
continent puisque le tunnel sous la
manche vient de refaire surface au
sommet franco-britannique apaisement à
l'état où tous les syndicats sauf la cgt
ont cessé leur mouvement de grève
sale temps pour les trafiquants de
drogue de nombreuses prises ont été
réalisées cette semaine par les polices
du monde entier
mais là messieurs bonsoir la confusion
et la violence en nouvelle calédonie la
confusion avec la réapparition de
l'agriculteur européens qui avaient été
donnés pour morts pendant toute la
journée d'hier avec les réactions que
vous savez sur place et dans le monde
politique
en fait monsieur guérin est bien vivant
choquée mais vivant il été roué de coups
par un groupe de mélanésiens avant
d'être laissé pour mort ce qui explique
la méprise d'hier mais la violence quand
même dans cette région au nord du
territoire et la mort confirmée d'un
autre europe 1 qui a été tué au cours
d'un affrontement entre communautés six
personnes ont été blessées au cours de
l'accrochage et les mélanésiens affirme
qu'un des leurs a également été tués
mais il n'y a là aucune confirmation
un climat extrêmement tendu comme le
montre le reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux
jean-michel mercurol et en régaler
père de cinq enfants monsieur meyer 56
ans est le premier mort de cette
guérilla commencé entre blancs de
nouvelle calédonie et mélanésiens c'est
aujourd'hui dans le nord de l'île à
400km de nouméa que la fusillade a
éclaté la famille et des amis de
monsieur guérin attaqué hier dans sa
ferme par des kanaks ramener le vieil
homme blessé pour la faire soigner
devant le refus des indépendantistes de
laisser passer la voiture à un barrage
les premiers tirs ont été échangés
personne ne sait encore qui a ouvert le
feu en premier et entre 4 500 cuisine si
la fusillade coin il y avait les bars à
lui même et puis des quêteurs elle
partout qui étaient postés et puis ans a
tiré dans tous les sens problème
première intervention sérieuse de la
gendarmerie avec l'envoi de commandos
héliportés sur les lieux
première arrestation de quatre kanak
impliqués dans la fusillade
les échanges de coups de feu outre la
mort de monsieur mézières tué d'une
balle dans le ventre a fait aussi
plusieurs victimes parmi les mélanésiens
sur son lit d'hôpital monsieur guérin se
remet lentement de la tacc d'hier sa
femme blessée par balle à l'épaule lors
de sa fuite en voiture est toujours
hospitalisée et on lui vend jour les
remarques et les menaces qui pèsent sur
tous les fermiers isolé dans la brousse
ou sur les métropolitains habitants des
villages du nord de l'île ont conduit
les responsables à accélérer les
évacuations des familles personnes âgées
femmes enfants
des par voie aérienne vers lui mais un
24 heures ont été difficiles pour pas
spécialement à domaine c'est partout
pareil
les maisons brûlées bétail abattu la
situation s'aggrave en nouvelle
calédonie et ils la communauté blanche
sur tout s'organise qu'on signale la
présence dans l'île d'une cinquantaine
de mercenaires français et allemand
recruté pour défendre les fermiers nous
avons rencontré l'un d'eux c'est pour
les caldoches
pour qu'est la paix dans ce pays
le parti communiste a nié le marxisme
est le pouvoir sous ce territoire dans
le nord de l'île la peur a fait place à
la haine ce n'est pas encore
l'embrasement général mais les
indépendantistes du fln car ont
semble-t-il beaucoup de mal à contrôler
leurs troupes
surtout les jeunes oui trois compagnies
de crs viennent tout juste d'arriver en
nouvelle calédonie pour renforcer les
gendarmes qui sont déjà là bas alors
l'émissaire du gouvernement monsieur
charles barbou a quitté aujourd'hui la
nouvelle calédonie pour rendre compte à
paris de sa mission et de son côté le
ministre de l'intérieur a rendu hommage
à tous ceux qui en nouvelle calédonie
ont contribué à éviter que la violence
ne prenne le pas sur la raison et le
dialogue monsieur joxe qui indique que
le gouvernement prendra de nouvelles
décisions ou vue de la mission de
monsieur barbe et plus a signalé deux
prises de position d'abord celle de
l'église protestante ou plus précisément
de l'église évangélique de nouvelle
calédonie qui se prononcent pour
l'indépendance quant à claude labbé le
président du groupe rpr l'assemblée
nationale il estime et je le cite
textuellement que le gouvernement a pris
la voie du racisme et de l'apartheid
tels qu'ils existent en afrique du sud
alors au delà des événements qui se
produisent aujourd'hui sur le terrain et
des réactions politiques les plus
diverses vous venez de l'entendre on a
beaucoup évoqué l'importance pour la
france d'être présente en nouvelle
calédonie une importance qui est d'abord
stratégique
l'histoire l'a prouvé mais aussi un rôle
politique et peut-être un enjeu décisif
pour l'avenir
écoutez les explications d'un
spécialiste des problèmes internationaux
si vous voulez prendre une image c'est
comme un immense porte-avions émerger
qui contrôle l'ensemble du pacifique sud
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale pour
donner un exemple de l'importance de
cette île c'est à partir de ces teams
que les américains ont lancé leur
contre-offensive vers le vers le japon
et que donc elle contrôle si vous voulez
toutes les approches vers les grandes
routes maritimes du [ __ ] heures de la
chine etc
ça c'est le saas et le premier point le
deuxième point qui est qui est à la fois
stratégique et politique c'est
qu'évidemment la perte de cette île
pourrait entraîner un mouvement
de domino si vous voulez sur l'ensemble
des autres possessions françaises dans
le pacifique sont plus plus vers le nord
et en particulier les îles de la société
tahiti qui font de la france
et ça on oublie trop souvent la
troisième puissance maritime du monde
avec plus de 2 millions de kilomètres
carrés de mer donc de zone économique
exclusive
et le troisième point c'est que cette
zone du pacifique c'est aussi la zone du
développement de l'avenir pour
l'ensemble de l'économie mondiale
jusqu'à présent la france a investi
l'essentiel de son aide économique et
militaire en afrique et surtout en
afrique de l'ouest et on peut réellement
se poser la question
à l'aube du xxième siècle de savoir si
un pays qui vont rester une puissance
moyenne globale comme la france n'a pas
intérêt à diversifier son add militaires
et politiques et à s'orienter là aussi
vers le pacifique et donc de ce point de
vue ce qui se passe en nouvelle
calédonie et ce qui risque de se passer
par la suite à tahiti peut avoir des
conséquences globales est très
importante pour la politique de la
france en ethiopie les vivres continuent
d'arriver pour venir en aide aux
victimes de la famine à ce jour ce sont
7 millions de personnes qui sont ainsi
menacées par la faim et la malnutrition
un problème extrêmement douloureux dans
un pays où on estime le nombre de
victimes à 300 milles depuis neuf mois
aujourd'hui l'effort international est
très important mais toujours insuffisant
il est responsable les éthiopiens lancer
un nouveau cri d'alarmé devant la
rupture des stocks
nous avons un témoignage à vous
présenter ce soir sur la situation dans
ce pays du bout du monde
ces témoignages c'est celui d'un
responsable des nations unies qui
revient justement d'ethiopie écoutez le
et ce pays vous paraîtra peut-être plus
proche de nous
dans quelques heures ce bébé sera mort
c'est une certitude comme celui là ils
sont plus de 500 milan ac ici dans ce
camp au nord d'addis abeba la famine de
cette année est l'une des plus grandes
du siècle ils meurent en masse depuis
six mois
ici c'est la solution de la dernière
chance
une sonde pour nourrir de force ce corps
abandonnés l'image qui me reste encore à
l'esprit c'est celle de cette jeune mère
qui se précipitent vers nous à mon
arrivée et qui me dit dans mon enfant
avec toi tu n'es plus de quoi lui donner
à manger
je ne veux pas qu'il meure dans mes bras
elle me suivait elle me suivait et
soudain j'ai vu l'enfant s'évanouir plus
de panique je les prix j'ai commencé à
courir vers la tente médicale
trop tard il est mort dans mes bras
l'histoire de cet enfant qui avait trois
ans et qui pesait 4 kg alors que la
plupart des bébés dans les pays
occidentaux pèse 3 kilos et demi et 4 kg
à la naissance donc l'histoire de cet
enfant était une histoire de 15000
personnes qui meurent de faim chaque
semaine en ethiopie évidemment il est
très difficile d'établir des
statistiques parce que la plupart des
populations sont dans des régions
inaccessibles mais il est sûr que la
sécheresse menace aujourd'hui plus de 7
millions de personnes
et de fait c'est tout le nord de ce pays
grand comme deux fois la france qui est
sinistrée
ce qui complique l'acheminement de
l'aide internationale c'est que les
zones les plus touchées sont celles où
la guérilla érythréenne et tigréenne
opposent une résistance farouche aux
armes et d'addis abeba pourtant depuis
quelques semaines
l'aide alimentaire commence à arriver
dans ces provinces
les centaines de milliers de tonnes de
poudre de l'aide de sucre et de céréales
mais c'est loin d'être suffisant
pour vous donner une idée depuis
l'explosion des médias à anvers
l'ethiopie en octobre dernier
la communauté internationale a promis
190 mille tonnes de céréales alors que
selon le gouvernement égyptien
rien que pour couvrir les besoins de 50%
de la population
il faut cinq cent soixante trois mille
tonnes de céréales quelle que soit
l'aide internationale on sait déjà que
900 mille hommes femmes et enfants
mourront d'ici noël images auxquelles
aucun ne parvient décidément pas à
s'habituer un bon sommet
franco-britannique avec des discussions
très positives la rencontre thatcher
mitterrand s'est donc bien passé comme
d'ailleurs à chaque fois semble-t-il
margaret thatcher qui a d'ailleurs mis à
profit sa présence en france pour
participer au conseil franco britannique
qui se tenait cet après-midi en avignon
il s'agit d'un rendez-vous formel entre
les deux premiers ministres français et
britannique pour discuter des problèmes
bilatéraux avec aujourd'hui en toile de
fond la situation de l'europe et
l'éventualité de l'adhésion de l'espagne
et du portugal les viticulteurs français
qui ne sont pas d'accord avait décidé de
le faire savoir
maryse manon canaliser coincé entre le
rôle d'un côté et les remparts de la
cité d'avignon de l'autre
trois mille agriculteurs du midi ont
défilé cet après midi à l'appel de la
fnsea est déçu angie a il y avait
presque un gendarme par agriculteur ce
qui n'a pas empêché quelques incidents
juste avant l'arrivée de madame pas de
chair et de monsieur fabius venu
clôturer le conseil franco britannique à
avignon pour les producteurs de moutons
de fruits et légumes et de vin c'était
l'occasion de rappeler à deux jours du
sommet européen de dublin que ce sont
eux les producteurs méditerranéen qui
sont les plus menacés dans l'entrée de
l'espagne dans le marché commun car
c'est encore le vin qui sera au centre
des débats à dublin
à lui seul ce dossier peut compromettre
le succès du sommet des chefs d'état
revenons un instant sur le sommet d'hier
un sommet qui a permis non seulement de
préparer la réunion des chefs d'état et
de gouvernement européen dublin mais
aussi de faire le point des relations
entre paris et londres dès relations qui
s'affirme de plus en plus étroite
georges bordeaux les ministres et les
conseillers qui arrivé ce matin à
l'elysée on croyait à peine leurs yeux
pour la première fois depuis longtemps
l'entente cordiale était vraiment
cordiale les mesures étudiées ont décidé
en commun ce matin sont nombreuses et
souvent concrètes tunnel sous la manche
rapport des experts dans trois mois
armement surgénérateur satellite
ordinateur coopération
franco-britannique renforcée ajoutez y
la promesse d'une solidarité franco
britannique correct au prochain sommet
européen de dublin en juin dernier à
fontainebleau
françois mitterrand avait rendu un grand
service à madame thatcher en réglant le
problème de la contribution britannique
aux finances européennes belle joueuse
madame thatcher a su se montrer
reconnaissante
revoilà donc ce tunnel sous la manche ce
georges bortoli vous le disais il ya un
instant un groupe de travail doit
remettre un rapport dans les trois mois
qui viennent sur ce projet
le projet qui n'est plus de toute
jeunesse et qui verra peut-être le jour
sait-on jamais en tout cas les délais
donnés aux experts laisse penser que
c'est du sérieux cette fois mais rien
est impossible puisque le premier coup
de pioche du serpent de mer sous la
manche a été donné en 1881 il y à 104
ans thierry voilà plus de deux siècles
que le premier projet de tunnel sous la
manche a été conçu par un français
l'ingénieur des marins les guerres
franco anglaise la révolution et les
aventures napoléonienne ont retardé les
premiers coups de pioche jusqu'en 1880 à
l'époque de la reine victoria et de
l'entente cordiale à chaque guerre
mondiale le royaume uni a rangé le
projet dans les cartons
il n'a reçu rhji que lorsque la
grande-bretagne est entrée dans le
marché commun là c'est devenu plus
sérieux
près d'un km de galeries ont été
creusées de part et d'autre du channel
l'angleterre toujours réticentes décider
seul d'abandonner les travaux en 1975
le climat revient-il à l'entente
cordiale avec margaret thatcher et
françois mitterrand toujours est il
qu'un accord vient d'être à nouveau
signé entre paris et londres
pour l'instant il ne s'agit que de
constituer un groupe de travail chargé
d'examiner le cahier des charges et de
prévoir les modalités de participation
de groupes privés à la construction du
tunnel
madame thatcher restait opposée au
projet temps qui la tête à l'initiative
de sociétés nationalisées
avec la privatisation la dame de fer
s'affirme prudemment optimiste si tout
va bien une décision définitive pourrait
intervenir dès l'an prochain
d'ailleurs les promoteurs privés ont
déjà cinq projets différents des tunnels
de pont et même un pont tunnel qui ne
s'enfoncerait sous la mer qu'au milieu
du pas de calais aura bien les fumeurs
français vont peut-être bientôt
retrouver leur petit nuage avec la
détente du côté de la setac car tous les
syndicats sauf la cgt ont décidé de
cesser leur mouvement de grève
avec un point noir la capitale où les
rayons des buralistes risque fort de
rester vide quelques jours ou quelques
semaines encore
jean marc dubois les parisiens risquent
de trouver ces rouleaux encore pour
quelques jours à la place de leurs
cigarettes favorite notamment les
fumeurs de brunes
en effet depuis mercredi le magasin de
la seita en plaine saint denis qui
approvisionne paris et sa banlieue est
bloqué et le restera ce week-end ce soir
la france des fumeurs est donc coupée en
deux d'un côté les parisiens qui
connaîtront encore quelques restrictions
et de l'autre le reste de la france où
la situation s'améliore nettement
la majorité des usines de la seita
fonctionne normalement et
l'approvisionnement sera bientôt
rétablie c'est le résultat d'une semaine
de négociations entre syndicats et
gouvernement pour trouver une solution
au conflit qui dure depuis plus d'un
mois et qui porte sur le nouveau statut
des employés
le secrétariat d'état au budget va
étudier les propositions et donnera une
réponse dans les prochains jours en
attendant ce soir seule la cgt continue
a appelé ses adhérents à la poursuite de
la grève mais en des termes mesurés
conséquence les bureaux de tabac
recevront peut-être à nouveau leurs
cigarettes et puisque nous parlons
bureau de tabac je vous rappelle qu'il
ne vous reste qu'une journée pour
acheter
votre vignette da partir de dimanche cet
autocollant qui répond au doux nom de
taxe additionnelle sur les véhicules
automobiles vous coûtera que 3 % de plus
le premier mois et 1% supplémentaire
les mois suivants enfin vous devez aussi
savoir toujours en social que les
mineurs de fer de lorraine ont décidé
cet après midi de suspendre la grève
générale illimitée qu'ils observaient
depuis le 19 nov
à l'étranger les alentours de
l'ambassade d'afrique du sud à
washington sont envahis depuis plusieurs
jours par des militants anti apartheid
ils protestent contre la discrimination
raciale en afrique du sud et
l'arrestation de treize leaders
syndicaux de la communauté noire dans ce
pays hier les manifestants se sont un
peu frotté à la police tandis que
l'ambassadeur d'afrique du sud
comparé la situation de son ambassade à
la prise d'otage des américains à
téhéran
une petite phrase qui ne digère pas le
département d'état américain
cent mille polonais se serait réfugié en
allemagne fédérale depuis le coup d'état
du général jarre usain ski des chiffres
que vient encore gonflé de nouvelles
défections particulièrement nombreuse
depuis quinze jours avec une filière
maintenant classique les ferries qui
font les liaisons sur la baltique 427
polonais avait profité d'une croisière
la semaine dernière pour demander
l'asile politique en allemagne de
l'ouest
quinze nouveaux passagers ont fait de
même cette semaine en profitant d'une
escale mercredi soir mais chez l'ombre
dans le brouillard de la mer du nord
l'euro galine amorce un accostage
délicat - sur le plan maritime qu'en
termes politiques
sur les mille touristes touristes entre
guillemets qu'il répondra sur hambourg
il est des vins certain qu'une bonne
poignée de passagers ne retournera plus
à bord ce petit jeu plein de drames
humains dure depuis des années mais il
s'accélère de façon spectaculaire depuis
quelques semaines ce voyageur est par
exemple très évasif quant à son
intention de retourner sur l'euro galine
et ces dames qui dit vouloir visiter des
amis à hanovre éclate d'un rire entendu
lorsqu'on interroge sur la date de son
retour en pologne
fasciné par les vitrines surtout celles
des magasins d'alimentation de la
société de consommation occidentale
nous retrouvons quatre réfugiés parmi
les 430 qui sont arrivés et rester à
hambourg brême et travaux wind peur du
passé et craintes face à l'avenir ils
nous ont confié que leur prénom refusé
de nous dire leur ville d'origine
une poignée de dollars péniblement
économiser en poche il part à l'assaut
de l'ouest de l'europe mais aussi du
canada et des états unis
pour l'instant donc l'allemagne fédérale
traite à l'amiable toutes les demandes
polonaises de droit d'asile le poids de
la dette historique allemande explique
largement cette générosité m
durera-t-elle
reste que l'on assiste depuis un mois à
une accélération du flux des polonais
qui choisissent l'exode via les
paquebots de la baltique
à cela deux raisons l'aggravation de la
crise en pologne mais aussi la crainte
qu'en début d'année 85
les frontières ne se ferme en pologne où
surtout que l'allemagne et le monde
occidental en crise refusent
d'accueillir de nouveaux réfugiés
un quart d'heure d'interview avec nos
quatre fugitifs de hambourg permet de
dresser un tableau à la fois précis et
sombre de la situation en pologne
la blonde alice yahé les copies de va
les a que sont andré yann et yosef se
veulent avant tout des réfugiés
économiques
ils n'ont pas eu d'ennuis politique
distille avec le régime et ils ont
surtout fui une misère qui leur fait
percevoir la vie dans un camp de
réfugiés comme une sorte de luxe malgré
un cercle trois à quatre mois de salaire
cette somme leur a permis distille de
payer une croisière après une attente de
six mois auprès d'une agence de voyage
d'état en clair c'est avec la
bénédiction des autorités polonaises
qu'ils ont quitté leur pays bénéficiant
d'une filière quasi gouvernemental d'une
soupape qui permet de diminuer les
tensions surtout économique et social en
pologne une bonne semaine pour les
policiers français de la lutte anti
drogue avec une jolie prise à toulon où
ils ont arraisonné un voilier qui
transportait deux tonnes et demie de
haschich une prise importante qui se
produit au moment où les polices du
monde entier viennent de réussir des
coups fumants dans leur combat contre
les stupéfiants la preuve apparemment tu
que la collaboration commence à porter
ses fruits
l'enquète de patrice pollet et alain
quand c'est ce samedi dernier dans
l'après midi la police intercepte ce
bateau le sne à petit à son bord deux
tonnes 650 de marijuana le bateau était
sous surveillance depuis son passage aux
antilles une filature qui a payé l'année
84 marque un tournant dans l'histoire
des grosses prises de drogue à travers
le monde
en pleine jungle à 1000 km de bogota
après une résistance armée 12 tonnes de
cocaïne sont saisis sur un petit
aéroport leur record mondial
octobre à marseille la police fait main
basse sur dix tonnes de cannabis la plus
grosse prise française
et puis ce mois ci une suite
d'opérations déclenchée par la police
américaine va encore alourdir les pertes
des trafiquants au mexique
douze mille tonnes de marijuana 100
volts en fumée
300 arrestations suivront et trois mille
paysans encadrés par les trafiquants
seront libérés
dans la mer des caraïbes vingt gardes
côtes américains aidés par la marine des
etats unis participent à une gigantesque
opération qui permettra de saisir 250
tonnes de drogues diverses
cette manoeuvre permettra de couper en
partie la route de la drogue en
provenance de colombie novembre toujours
quatre hommes sont arrêtés en arizona
il s'apprêtait à transporter près de 700
kilos de cocaïne par avion valeur de la
prise
un milliard de dollars et de l'autre
côté du globe à hong kong une tonne
d'héroïne et trouver sur des bateaux les
trafiquants ont la vie dure
s'il a fallu attendre 84 pour voir la
lutte contre le trafic de drogue
progressé d'un bond gigantesque c'est
qu'il semble que la collaboration tant
souhaité par certaines polices soit
enfin une réalité pour que d'abord c'est
qu'il ya beaucoup de drogue dans le
monde soit c'est un premier point mais
je crois surtout qu'il ya une prise de
conscience absolument mondial de la
nécessité de lutter contre le trafic des
drogues
je reviens de réunion une au brésil pour
les pays d'amérique du sud une autre à
el paso avec les pays d'amérique du nord
et c'est manifeste à tous les niveaux et
tous les pays se rencontrer ce même
désir profond de lutter contre la drogue
par tous les moyens
troisièmement je pense aussi qu'il y ait
un très sérieux effort qui est fait par
les pays qui on consomme le plus je veux
parler notamment des pays d'europe et
des pays tels états unis ainsi qu'une
collaboration accrue de toucher pays
atteler au même problème de la drogue on
en produit de plus en plus à travers le
monde pour la production du cannabis est
presque le glow banquiers qu'il faut
recouvrir maintenant de marque rouge
les etats unis qui à l'origine ne
produisait pas de cannabis se retrouve
aujourd'hui parmi les fournisseurs les
plus importants de cette drogue
quant à l'héroïne et à la cocaïne leur
production est de plusieurs centaines de
tonnes par an c'est aux états unis qu'en
grande partie la drogue termine son
voyage près de 22 millions d'américains
ont essayé la cocaïne l'année dernière
de plus en plus cher à des millions et
des millions d'américains et des
transports c'est leur vie tant
professionnel que familial total
étrangement ici cette drogue bénéficient
d'une relative tolérance et même d'une
certaine bienveillance
c'est la roxy la drogue à la mode son
usage se répand de plus en plus
formellement pour les professions
libérales les cadres tous ceux qui
travaillent dans ces building
dans une des jets la cocaïne est la
drogue une partie de la bourgeoisie
américaine le gouvernement américain a
voulu frapper très fort avant que ce
groupe devienne la drogue de monsieur
tout le monde
nous avons beaucoup parlé de ce que l'on
appelle les nouveaux pauvres des gens
que souvent nous rencontrons nous
croisons et que le plus souvent nous
ignorons leur situation devient plus
cruelle encore alors qu'approchent les
fêtes de noël mais noël c'est aussi un
état d'esprit peut-être un peu de bonne
volonté a bien sûr ça ne change pas
fondamentalement les choses mais il ya
au moins un peu d'espoir et même de
solidarité c'est en tout cas le thème
d'une opération menée par l'armée du
salut toujours très présente en cette
période de l'année
l'armée du salut qui organise une
opération intitulée le pain de taux
voisins
emmanuel 30000 petit pain vendu ce soir
70000 du moins on l'espère demain près
de 400 bénévoles de l'armée du salut ont
installé leurs stands partout dans paris
pour cette opération le pain de ton
voisin bénéfice espéré un million de
francs une somme qui servira tout
d'abord à éponger le déficit de
l'opération soupe de nuit de l'hiver
dernier avec le reste des sommes
collectées l'armée du salut poursuivra
cet hiver son oeuvre en faveur de ce
qu'on appelle les nouveaux pauvres
l'an dernier l'organisation a servi près
de 5000 soupe de nuit aux plus démunis
cette année on prévoit une très forte
augmentation de la demande
vingt-cinq mineurs passeront sans doute
distribué à paris par l'armée du salut
c'est un genre et nous servir à
continuer notre action des soupes de
nouilles que nous organisons maintenant
depuis 1982 si vous organisez un fait de
d'aller un peu plus loin dans cette
rencontre vers les gens essayer non
seulement de leur apporter leur repas
chaud la nuit là où ils se trouvent mais
essayez aussi de de trouver avec une
solution à leur handicap on ne peut pas
accepter que des gens vivent la nuit
dehors
surtout en hiver comme celle du secours
catholique et des autres oeuvres de
charité cette initiative de l'armée du
salut vient compléter les mesures
gouvernementales annoncées à la mi
octobre des mesures techniques axées sur
trois points la fourniture d'un
hébergement d'urgence
la répartition des surplus alimentaires
pommes de terre viande et le logement
pour les financer le gouvernement a
d'ailleurs débloqué cette année 200
millions de francs une opération qui
semble donc avoir été bien accueilli par
les parisiens nous passons aux sports
maintenant avec lionel chamoulaud qui
revient sur les internationaux de tennis
d'australie sur la victoire de la petite
peugeot en grande bretagne et sur le
match de boxe de demain
grimm à ce choc de navratilova pourtant
à melbourne elle a remporté sa 72e
victoire de suite un record vient
également pour les françaises sophie
amiach et pascale paradis toujours en
cours au troisième tour paradis
rencontre chris evert blog tenue chic
pour le retour de mcnamara blessé en
mars 83 ce pantalon cache en fait une
française métallique qu'il porte aux
jeunes une sur gazon les serveurs comme
scanlan se régalent les pensées aussi
forgé benhabylès passe l'inde est le
favori en l'absence de mcenroe et le
prochain adversaire de benhabylès
accueil et trio royal pour la 205 turbo
16 au rallye de grande bretagne fin de
saison époustouflant pour le finlandais
vatanen est à peugeot en cinq sorties
depuis le tour de corse
c'est la troisième victoire consécutive
pour la 205 peugeot devient le grand
favori pour le titre mondial 85
cinquante kilos 800 c'est le poids du
français antoine monteiro son adversaire
le mexique à un canot accuse le même
poids 50 kilos 800 tous deux sont à 2
gran du poids maximum de la catégorie
des mouche
ils se ressemblent se serrent la main
mais à l'issue du combat de ce soir à
grenoble un seul le vainqueur pourra
tenter sa chance pour le titre mondial
des poids mouche oui cette rencontre
monteiro canot sera retransmise demain
après midi dans les jeux du stade les
pronostics de pierrette brès maintenant
pour le tiercé qui se court demain saint
cloud il y à 21 partants pour ce prix de
cluny et pierrette vous suggère de jouer
le 4 las le 15 le 16 le 7 le neuf le 11
et le 20 la météo matelas avec bougies
de simonetta est attendu coiffeur terry
se dégrade
oui oui mais ce n'est tout de même pas
sans nostalgie que nous fêterons le mois
de novembre
et en ce moment les ingénieurs météo
font les calculs mais on sait d'ores et
déjà que le moins neuf ans en 1984 et le
plus chaude tous les mois neuf ans
depuis 1890 et la journée de demain n'y
pourra rien changer si ce n'est donc cet
écrin dation regardez la photo satellite
l'anticyclone vous le savent et s'en va
de plus en plus vers l'est l'élément
nouveau aujourd'hui c'est l'arrivée
d'une perturbation qui a touché surtout
la bretagne elle perdra son activité au
fur et à mesure qu'elle progresse à elle
progressera vers l'intérieur du pays sur
le nord en revanche sur le sud est elle
sera ré alimentés par le mauvais temps
qui va remonter d'espagne c'est pourquoi
sur la carte de demain accompagnés de
fortes rafales de vents les nuages les
plus noires sont sur le sud ouest on
peut s'attendre à des averses assez
violente sur le nord-ouest quart nord
ouest
il s'agira surtout de nuages enfin
persistance du beau temps sur tout le
flanc est
les températures bien qu'en légère
baisse reste exceptionnelle pour la
saison de 9 à 13 degrés sur la moitié
nord de 13 à 18 degrés sur la moitié sud
c'est presque trop doux pour être vrai
demain samedi premier jour du mois de
décembre le soleil ses lèvres à 8h22 se
couchera 16h56 et nous fêterons d'accord
une île flottante
c'était avec l'hôte qui vous présentera
les dernières informations vers 22h50
juste après impôts strauss
nous reprenons le rythme du week end
avec toujours à 12h40 cinquantaine de
midi mais aussi à 17h50
le magazine de la rédaction bonsoir à
demain 20 heures